now joe biden's dismal poll numbers
continue to worsen as the crisis mount
and more voters sour on his job
performance a new issues and insight
poll released today found that only 19
percent of voters surveyed chose biden
as their preferred democratic nominee in
2024 by the way that put him nearly 10
points behind i'm not sure meanwhile
more recent studies and surveys show
that he's losing ground with key
demographics that helped elect him in
the first place particularly suburban
voters
one npr poll conducted in february found
biden's approval among suburban voters
dropped from over 10 points from the end
of 2021 a 12 point drop among suburban
women his approval with young voters one
of his strongest groups in the 2020
election that's a mystery to me now sits
at a mere 41 percent and despite the
abysmal poll numbers white house chief
of staff ron klain took a pretty bizarre
victory lap after the french president
macron's re-election this weekend
despite macron's 36 approval rating
seemingly implying that biden can win uh
in 2024 with the quinnipiac poll of 33
percent anyway here with reaction
outnumbered co-host kaylee mcinney and
the author of the soon to be released
suppression deception snobbery and bias
why the press gets so much wrong and
just does not care by the way you can
get a first edition copy on amazon.com
or hannity.com fox news contributor ari
fleischer is with us uh kaylee let me
start with you it's every demographic
independence he's down to 26 percent uh
hispanic americans he's down to 26
he's down with suburban voters
african-americans uh the youth vote
every single demographic
he's down dramatically
and i'm looking at the policies he's
putting in place and i don't see any
movement at all towards making the
adjustments that one might make if they
want to turn things around
no in fact he's taking the advice of
senator warren who said he needs to
double down on these progressive
policies and make good on them that is
not the answer sean but the reason he's
doing this you know this kind of olive
branch on student loans the rolling back
of title 42 there was some reporting
that oh maybe he's not going to roll it
back he always was because here's the
problem sean he's losing that aoc wing
of the party um he has to keep them um
so he can he doesn't have time to try to
salvage those independent suburban moms
because what he's having to do is
appease the radical left and sean i just
have to say that chief of staff tweet
he's severely delusional but those are
the kinds of things that joe biden is
hearing in the oval office his advisors
his minions are coming to him you're
doing great don't listen to what they're
saying
out on cable news you're winning mr
president he's in an echo chamber of
bliss and euphoria that simply does not
exist
let me read this sorry fleischer you're
a great communicator you know mark penn
well-respected democratic pollster he
said these economic blows are not just
one element and a cascading set of
problems all hitting at the same time it
combines the nuclear anxieties of the
50s and 60s with the inflation threat of
the 70s the crime wave of the 80s and
90s and the tensions over illegal
immigration in the 2000s and beyond then
he says this this electorate is not
experiencing a malaise as president
jimmy carter
once said to have proclaimed but has
instead formed a deep national fissure
ready to blow like a geyser in the next
election if the leadership does not move
to relieve the pressure
now that's a democratic pollster that's
a pretty deep profound prediction on his
part and i agree with every word of it
well it's also just very in touch isn't
it with the man on the street the woman
on the street the people for all these
years now who are just fed up with
everything that's going on where
nothing's going better and then joe
biden came along and made all these
promises and has bumbled and fumbled his
way through everything
look let me let me break down the body
numbers in two different ways for 2022
the midterm election nothing's going to
change it the historical tide against
parties in the first term of a
presidency combined with all of biden's
problems in the nation's problems it's
already the kiss of death for the
democrats
for 2024 history tells us that
presidents who lose and get clobbered in
the midterm can come back as bill
clinton did and as barack obama did but
joe biden can't and the reason sean i
say that with such a such assurance is
the democrat party is not going to want
an 80-year-old in decline to lead the
party particularly after they lose the
house after they lose the senate and
when he's so unpopular even if things
turn around in two years and the economy
seems to get strong things change joe
biden will not be at the helm of the
democratic party it just will not happen
okay so if you look at the washington
post last week kaylee uh they had joe
biden won if he runs again as the lead
then they put pete boo to judge
interestingly ahead of kamala harris he
was two she was three
and then a list of people that i don't
think inspire confidence in anybody but
i think that the the one thing that it
makes ari's prediction correct more than
any other one thing
is the fact that they're incapable of
giving in to their radical base
and and saying something like bill
clinton said the era of big government
is over or the under welfare as we know
it that that doesn't exist within this
radical party
no that's a bygone era even president
obama knew what was good for himself at
some points disagree with him entirely
however on at least some issues he knew
that he needed to track a little bit
toward the middle that is gone though
you're exactly right though when you
look at that tracker it is interesting
sean there's reporting that in the west
wing there are whispers you know kamal
is done pete buddha judge is the new
person we're looking to but what i'm
interested in is that poll that you put
up sean that not sure is more popular
than joe biden it's joe biden and kamala
than not sure there is no bench in this
party sean you look at the republican
party you have our standard bearer
president trump um but you've also got a
huge deep bench of people from tim scott
to ron desantis it's exciting christy
known we've got so many great people
they've got not sure that's who they
have
yeah now let's say if donald trump
decided to run i would argue ari
fleischer that every single day with
every failed policy and every bad
decision joe biden makes
that he's handing the keys back to
donald trump if i was donald trump i'd
almost play like joe biden i would do my
rallies i would do interviews with
non-hostile you know with non-hostile
media why get in a fight with media that
hates your guts it doesn't seem to
matter i would
prosecute the case against joe how bad
his policies are remind people what he
did and tell people how he's going to
get us out of the mess that joe created
and say god bless you god bless america
good night
well i think we should also bear in mind
how successful america was under
president trump's policies particularly
for child poverty rates for the
unemployment rates for blacks for
hispanics so many of the economic
indicators people have talked about for
years to help people from the bottom
rise up were all kicking into high gear
under donald trump and then covet hit
that's a huge success story now the
issue that democrats of course will have
against donald trump is they love to
hate him and so do they get a boost in
turnout if donald trump is the candidate
beyond what they would get against any
other candidate but i don't think it
matters for joe biden none of that plays
into it i think that joe biden is it's
inevitable sean in early 2023 shortly
after the midterm shellac and joe biden
is going to succumb to the pressure that
will build up inside the democratic
party and announce he's not running for
re-election democrats will be jumping at
the bit to get out of the starting gates
right after the november election which
is just six months from now just a
little over six months from now this is
going to be upon us real soon
i agree with you i i'm not even sure and
polls even indicate most people not sure
that he's going to finish his first term
the idea of a second term
i'm just not buying it
ari looking forward to your book thank
you great to see you kaylee always good
to have you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else